a few people asked about
depression and suicide it's a
this this is a russian program so we'll
have to go there
and i think about leonard cohen and one
of the things that always
kind of um broke my heart
and kind of suffocated the hope i have
for just
uh i don't know for love in a person's
life
is to hear how much th how much
depression was a part of leonard cohen's
life
and how much he suffered i guess one way
i'm not sure where we can go with this
question but
do you think about the places that the
mind can go
like these dark places yeah is there
something like where the only escape out
is suicide for example that's the
darkest version of it that
i really think suicide is a big place
in suicidal ideation and self-harm and
we don't talk a lot about it
it's it's a similar problem to trying to
talk about trans
these are umbrella categories and if the
commonality is
that somebody harms themselves but we
don't know whether that's coming because
of a problem in brain chemistry because
of an event
in their life whether evolutionary
programming for suicide is
weirdly normal whether or not it might
have a religious motivation
there's there's too many different forms
of self-harm and something like the 10th
largest killer thereabouts
and i think that you know you can look
at it from different angles uh
i i'm old enough to have you know had
pete seeger come to my college when i
was at university
and to watch his good humor
in the face of all adversity um
i think of odetta i used to go to odetta
concerts any i don't know if you
you know who she is okay this is gonna
be one of the better days of your life
check out odetta when we're done with
the interview um
she was a civil rights figure but also
just had a profound
voice and great musicianship
these people were in the struggle right
and they
they saw lots of bad things happen and
they kept their humor about them
and you know the thing is
that you can take on the velcro merits
you know the pain of the
of the planet or you can try to do
something else which is to be a happy
warrior
even if the odds are terrible and the
and the cost of failure is catastrophic
so even when surrounded
by darkness but the thing is with
leonard cohen is he created such
beautiful music
and yet it's like anthony bourdain the
same
and yet they go to this dark place
and it could be it's easy to say it's
just biochemistry
no there's a linkage between this highly
generative creative
side and in some cases
dark depression in other cases not so
you can't say that it's tied
the genius and madness are always you
know co-traveling or that beauty
and pain are one and the same what you
can say is that there's a cluster
of people that tell you that for that
cluster there is a relationship between
the darkness and the beauty
and i do think that in part it's
squaring circles that can't be squared
you know that well we're just talking
before
about the inability to serve two perfect
systems the perfect
system of the wave equation and the
perfect system of even temperament
they're both perfect they're not
compatible and
once you realize that there is
perfection and an inability to make
contact with perfection
i think you know you recognize that
um there is no solution to this world
you